I find that um
large language models do have this
coding right so it's an extremely useful
application that is for a lot of people
um taking stack Overflow out of their
life in exchange for something that is
more efficient I feel that chat GPT is
like an intern that I have to
micromanage I've have been working with
people in the past who were less capable
than chat GPT
and I'm not saying this because I hate
people but they personally as human
beings there was something present that
was not there in church Liberty which
was why I was carving for them but uh
chair GPT is has an interesting ability
it does give people superpowers and the
people who feel threatened by them are
the prompt leaders they are the people
who do what chat CPT is doing right now
so if you are not creative if you don't
build your own thoughts if you don't
have actual plans in the world and your
only job is to summarize emails and to
expand uh the simple intentions into
emails again then chat CPT might look
like a threat but I believe that it is a
very beneficial technology that allows
us to create more interesting stuff and
make the world more beautiful and
fascinating if we find to build it into
our life on the right ways
so I'm quite fascinated by these large
language models but I also think that
they aren't by no means the final
development
and it's interesting to see how this
development progresses one thing that uh
the out of the box vanilla language
models have as a limitation is that they
have still some limited coherence and
ability to construct complexity
and even though they exceed human
abilities to do what what they can do
one shot
typically when you write a text with a
language model or using it or when you
write code for the language model it's
not one shot because there won't be bugs
in your program and design errors and
compiler errors and so on and your
language model can help you to fix those
things but this process is out of the
box not automated yet so there is a
management process that also needs to be
done
and there are some interesting
developments PB AGI and so on that are
trying to automate this this management
process as well and I suspect that soon
we are going to see a bunch of cognitive
architectures where every module is in
some sense a language model or something
equivalent and between the language
models we exchange suitable data
structures not English
and produce compound behavior of this
whole thing to do some of the
quote-unquote prompt engineering for you
yeah they create this as this kind of
cognitive architectures that do the
front engineering and you're just doing
the high high level
yeah meta prompt engineering
there are limitations in a language
model alone I feel that part of my mind
works similarly to a language model
which means I can yell into it a prompt
and it's going to give me a creative
response but I have to do something with
the points first I have to take it as a
generative artifact that may or may not
be true it can it's usually a
contribulation it's just an idea and
then I take this idea and modify it I
might build a new prompt that is
stepping off this idea and develops it
to the next level or it put it into
something larger or I might try to prove
whether it's true or make an experiment
and this is what the language models
right now are not doing yet but there's
also no technical reason for why they
shouldn't be able to do this so the way
to make a language model coherent is
probably not to use reinforcement
learning until it only gives you one
possible answer that is uh linking to
its source data but it's using this is a
component in the larger system that can
also be built by the language model or
is enabled by a language model
structured components or using different
Technologies I suspect that language
models will be an important stepping
stone in developing
different types of systems and one thing
that is is really missing in the form of
language models that we have today is
real-time World coupling right it's
difficult to do perception with a
language model and motor control with
the language model instead you would
need to have different type of of thing
that is working with it also the
language model is a little bit obscuring
but it's actually functionality is some
people associate the structure of the
neural network of the language model
with the nervous system and I think
that's the wrong intuition
and that neural networks are undec
nervous system they are more like
um 100 step functions that use
differentiable linear algebra to
approximate the correlation between
adjacent brain States it's basically a
function that moves the step system from
one representational state to the next
representational state right so it's if
you try to map this into a metaphor that
is closer to our brain imagine that you
would take a language model or a model
like Delhi that you use for instance
this image image guided diffusion to
approximate a camera image and use the
activation state of the neural network
to interpret the camera image which in
principle I think will be possible very
soon and you do this periodically and
now you look at these patterns how when
this thing interacts with the world
periodically look like as in time and
these time slices they are somewhat
equivalent to the activation state of
the brain at a given moment how's the
actual brain different
just the asynchronous
craziness for me it's fascinating that
they are so vastly different and yet in
some circumstances produce somewhat
similar Behavior right and the brain is
first of all different because it's a
self-organizing system where the
individual cell is an agent that is
communicating with the other agents
around it and is always trying to find
some solution and all the structure that
pops up is emerge instructor
so one way in which you could try to
look at this is that individual neurons
probably need to get a reward so they
become trainable which means they have
to have inputs that are not affecting
the metabolism of the cell directly but
their messages semantic messages that
tell the cell whether it says done good
or bad and in which direction it should
shift Its Behavior right once you have
such an input neurons become trainable
and you can train them to perform
computations by exchanging messages with
other neurons and parts of the signals
that they are exchanging in parts of the
computation that are performing are
control messages that perform management
tasks for other neurons and other cells
also suspect that the brain does not
stop at the boundary of neurons to other
cells but there are many adjacent cells
will be involved intimately in the
functionality of the brain and will be
instrumental in distributing rewards and
in managing its functionality
it's uh fascinating to think about what
those characteristics of the brain
enable you to do is that language models
cannot do so first of all it's there's a
different loss function Network when we
learn yeah and to me it's fascinating
that you can build a system that looks
at 800 million pictures and captions and
correlates them because I don't think
that the human nervous system could do
this
for us the world is only learnable
because the adjacent frames are related
and we can afford to discard most of
that information during learning we
basically take only in stuff that makes
us more coherent not less coherent and
our neural networks are willing to look
at data that is not making the neural
network coherent at first but only in
the long run by doing lots and lots
statistics eventually patterns become
visible and emerge and our mind seems to
be focused on finding the patterns as
early as possible yeah so filtering
early on yes not later yes it's a
slightly different Paradigm and it leads
to much faster convergence so we only
need to look the tiny fraction of the
data to become coherent and of course we
we do not have the same richness as our
trained models here we will not
incorporate the entirety of text in the
internet and be able to refer to it and
have all this knowledge available and
being able to confabulate over it
instead we have a much much smaller part
of it that is more deliberately built
and to me it would be fascinating to
think about how to build such systems
it's not obvious that they would
necessarily be more efficient than us on
a digital substrate but I suspect that
they might so I suspect that the actual
AGI that is going to be more interesting
is going to use slightly different
algorithmic paradigms or sometimes
massively different algorithmic
paradigms then the current generation of
Transformer based learning systems do
you think it might be using just a bunch
of language models like this do you
think
the current Transformer based large
language models will take us to AGI
and my main issue is I think that
they're quite ugly and uh which
brutalist yeah you said yes they are
basically brute forcing the problem of
thought
and uh by training the thing with
looking at instances where people have
thought and then trying to defect that
and if you have enough data the depak
becomes indistinguishable from the
actual phenomenon and in many
circumstances it's going to be identical
can you deep fake it till you make it
so can you achieve um what are the
limitations of this I mean can you
reason
let's use words that are loaded that's
that's that's a very interesting
question I I think that these models are
clearly making some inference but if you
give them a reasoning task it's often
difficult for the experimenters to
figure out whether the reasoning is the
result of the emulation of the reasoning
strategy that they saw in human written
text or whether it's something that the
system was able to infer by itself on
the other hand if you think of human
reasoning
um you if you want to become a very good
Reasoner you don't do this by just
figuring out yourself you read about
reasoning and the first people who try
to write about reasoning and reflect on
it didn't get it right like even
Aristotle who thought about this very
hard and came up with a theory of how
syllogisms works and syllogistic
reasoning has mistakes in his attempt to
build something like a formal logic and
gets maybe 80 right and the people that
are talking about reasoning
professionally today with tarsky and
Vega and built on their work so in many
ways people when they perform reasoning
are emulating what other people wrote
about reasoning right so that it's
difficult to really draw this boundary
and when Francois says that these models
are only interpolating between what they
saw and what other people are doing well
if you give them all the latent
dimensions of that can be extracted from
the internet what's missing maybe there
is almost everything there and if you're
not sufficiently informed by these
dimensions and you need more I think
that's not difficult to increase the
temperature in the large angles model to
the point that is producing stuff that
is maybe 90 nonsense and 10 viable and
combine this with some Hoover that is
trying to filter out the viable parts
from the nonsense in the same way as our
own thinking works right when we're very
creative we increase the temperature in
our own mind and recreate hypothetical
universes and solutions most of which
will not work and then we test and we
test by building a core that is
internally coherent and we use reasoning
strategies that use some axiomatic
consistency by which we can
identify those strategies and thoughts
and sub-universes that are viable and
that can expand our thinking so if you
look at the language models they have
clear limitations right now one of them
is they're not coupled to the world in
real time in the way in which our
nervous systems are so it's difficult
for them to observe themselves in the
universe and to observe what kind of
universe they're in second they don't do
real-time learnings they basically get
only trained with
algorithms that rely on the data being
available in batches so it can be
parallelized and runs efficiently on the
network and so on and real-time learning
would be very slow so far and
inefficient
that clearly is something that our
nervous systems can do to some degree
and there is a problem with these models
being coherent and I suspect that all
these problems are solvable without a
technological Revolution we don't need
fundamentally new algorithms to change
that for instance you can enlarge in the
context window and thereby basically
create working memory in which you train
everything that happens during the day
and if that is not sufficient you add a
database and you write some clever
mechanisms that the system learns to use
to swap out in and out stuff from its
prompt context right and if that is not
sufficient if your database is full in
the evening you'd overnight you just
train if the system is going to sleep
and dream and is going to train the
staff from its database into the larger
model by fine-tuning it building
additional layers and so on and then the
next day it starts with a fresh database
in the morning with fresh eyes and has
integrated all this stuff and you know
when you talk to people and you have
strong disagreements about something
which means that in their mind they have
a faulty belief or you have a faulty
belief result of dependencies on it very
often you will not achieve agreement in
one session but you need to sleep about
this once or multiple times for you
before you have integrated all these
necessary changes in your mind so maybe
it's already somewhat similar yeah right
there's already a latency even for
humans to update the model yeah and of
course we can combine the language model
with models that get coupled to reality
in real time and we can build multimodal
model and bridge between Vision models
and language models and so on so there
is no reason to believe that the
language models will necessarily run
into some problem that will prevent them
from becoming generally intelligent
but I don't know that it's just I don't
see a proof that they wouldn't my issue
is I don't like them I think that
they're inefficient I think that they
use way too much compute I think that
given the amazing Hardware that we have
we could build something that is much
more beautiful than our own mind and
this thing is not as beautiful than at
as our own mind despite being so much
larger
but it's a kind of proof of concept it's
the only thing that works right now
right so it's the it's not the only game
in town but it's the only thing that has
this utility with so much Simplicity and
there's a bunch of relatively simple
algorithms that you can understand in
relatively few weeks that can be scaled
up massively so it's the uh the deep
blue of Chess playing
yeah it's not it's ugly yeah called
China and hit this uh when you describe
chess suggested that there are two main
strategies in which you could play chess
one is that you are making a very
complicated plan that reaches far into
the future and you try not to make a
mistake while enacting it and this is
basically the human strategy and the
other strategy is that you are brute
forcing your way to success which means
you make a tree of possible moves where
you look at in principle every move that
is open to you or the possible answers
and you try to make this as deeply as
possible of course you optimize you cut
off trees that don't look very promising
and you use libraries of end game and
early game and so on to optimize this
entire process but this boot Force
strategy is how most of the chess
programs were built and this is how
computers get better than humans at
playing chess and um and I look at the
large language models I feel that I'm
observing the same thing it's basically
The Brute Force strategy to thought by
training this thing on pretty much the
entire internet and then in the limit it
gets coherent to a degree that
approaches human coherence yeah and on a
side effect it's able to do things that
no human could do right it's able to uh
sift through massive amounts of text
relatively quickly and summarize them
quickly and never lapses in attention
and I still have the illusion that when
I play with chat GPT that it's in
principle not doing anything that I
could not do if I had Google at my
disposal and I get all the resources
from the internet and spend enough time
on it but uh this this thing that I have
an extremely autistic stupid intern in a
way that is extremely good at directory
and I can offload the droidery to the
degree that I'm able to automate the
management of the intern is is something
that is difficult for me to overhype at
this point because we have not yet
started to scratch the surface of what's
possible with this but it feels like
it's a tireless intern or maybe it's an
army of interns
and so you get to command
these slightly incompetent creatures
and there's an aspect because of how
rapidly you can iterate with it
it's also part of the brainstorming part
of the
kind of inspiration for your own
thinking so you get to interact with the
thing I mean when I'm programming or
doing any kind of generational GPT is
it's somehow is a catalyst for your own
thinking in a way that I think an intern
might not be yeah it gets really
interesting I find is when you turn it
into a multi-agent system so for
instance
um you can get the system to generate a
dialogue between a patient and a doctor
very easily but what's more interesting
is you have one instance of chat CPT
that is the patient and you tell that in
the prompt what kind of complicated
syndrome it has and the other one is the
therapist who doesn't know anything
about the this patient and you just have
these two instances battling it out and
observe the psychiatrist or a
psychologist trying to analyze the
patient and trying to figure out what's
wrong with the patient and if you try to
take a very large problem the problem
for instance how to build a company and
you turn this into lots and lots of sub
problems then often you can get to a
level where the language model is able
to solve this what I also found
interesting is based on the observation
that chat GPT is pretty good at
translating between four angle language
but sometimes there's difficulty to
write very long coherent algorithms that
you need and you need to core write them
as human author why not design a
language that is suitable for this so
some kind of pseudo code that is more
relaxed than Python and that allows you
to sometimes specify a problem vaguely
in human terms and let the church repeat
take care of the take care of the rest
and you can use chat CPT to develop that
syntax for it and
develop new kinds of programming
paradigms in this way so we very soon
get to the point where this question
each old question for US computer
scientists versus the best spoken
language and can we write a better
provoking language now that this
um I think that almost every serious
computer scientist goes to a phase like
this in their life
this is a question that is almost no
longer relevant because what is
different between the programming
languages is not what the let the
computer do but what they let you think
about what the computer should be doing
and
now the threat GPT becomes an interface
to this in which you can specify in many
many ways what this computer should be
doing and chat GPT or some other
language model or combination of system
is going to take off the rest and allow
you expand the realm of thought you're
allowed to have when interacting with
the computer
it sounds to me like you're saying
there's basically no limitations your
intuition says to what larger language I
don't know of that limitation so when I
currently play with it it's quite
limited I wish that it was way better
but isn't that your fault versus the
larger I don't know of course it's
always my fault there's probably a way
to lose everything at all I just want to
get you on the record saying yes
everything is my fault that works
doesn't work in my life at least that is
usually the most useful perspective for
myself even though with hindsight I feel
no I sometimes wish I could have seen
myself as part of my environment more
and understand that a lot of people are
actually seeing me and looking at me and
not trying to make my life work in the
same way as I try to help others and
making this switch to uh this level 3
perspective is something that happened
long after my level four perspective in
my life and I wish that I could have had
it earlier and it's also not now that I
don't feel like I'm complete I'm all
over the place that's all where's
happiness in terms of stages is on three
and four no Take that tension you can be
happy at any stage or unhappy
but I think that if you are at a stage
where you get agency over how your
feelings are generated and to some
degree you start doing this when you
leave a dollar sense I believe that you
understand that you're in charge of your
own emotion to some degree and that you
are responsible how you approach the
world that it's basically your task to
have some basic hygiene how in the way
in which you deal with your mind and you
cannot blame your environment for the
way in which you feel but you live in a
world that is highly mobile and it's
your job to choose the environment that
you thrive in and to build it and
sometimes it's difficult to get the
necessary strengths and the energy to do
this and Independence and the worse you
feel the harder it is
but it's something that you learn
there's also this thing that we are
usually incomplete right I'm I'm a rare
mind which means I'm a mind that is
incomplete in ways that are harder to
complete so for me uh it might have been
harder to initially to find the right
relationships and friends that complete
me to the degree that I become an almost
functional human being
oh
man the search space of humans that
complete you is an interesting one
especially for your shabach that's an
interesting because talking about Brute
Force search in chess
yeah I wanna I wanna I wonder what that
search tree looks like
I think that my rational thinking is not
good enough to solve that task a lot of
problems in my life that I can
conceptualize as software problems and
the failure modes are bucks and they can
debug them and write software that take
care of the missing functionality
but the stuff that they don't understand
well enough to and uh to use my
analytical reasoning to solve the issue
and then I have to develop my intuitions
and often I have to do this with people
who are wiser than me and that's
something that's hard for me because I
don't have I'm not born with the
instinct to submit to other people's
wisdom yeah
so what kind of problems are we talking
about this is stage three like love
I found love was never hard
then
fitting into a world that most people
work differently than you and have
different intuitions of what should be
done ah
to empathy
um it's also
Aesthetics when you come into a world
where almost everything is ugly and you
come out of a world where everything is
beautiful I grew up in a beautiful place
and as a child of an artist yeah and um
in in this place it was mostly nature
everything had intrinsic Beauty
and everything was
built out of an intrinsic need for it to
work for itself everything that my
father created was something that he
made to get the world to work for
himself and I felt the same thing and
when I come out into the world and I am
asked to submit to lots and lots of
rules I'm asking okay when I observe
your stupid rules what is the benefit
and I see the life that is being offered
as a reward that's not attractive
when you were born and raised in
extraterrestrial Prince
in a world full of people wearing suits
so it's a it's a challenging integration
yes but it also means that I'm often
blind for the ways in which everybody is
creating their own bubble of
wholesomeness almost everybody and
people are trying to do it and for me to
discover this it was necessary that I
found people who had a similar shape of
Soul as myself so passive way I thought
these are my people people that um treat
each other in such a way as if they're
around for each other for eternity
how long how long does it take you to uh
to detect the geometry the shape of the
soul of another human to notice that
they might be one one of your kind
um sometimes it's instantly and I'm
wrong and sometimes it takes a long time
you believe in love at first sight yeah
yes but I also noticed that I have been
wrong
so uh sometimes I look at a person and
I'm just enamored by everything about
them and sometimes this persists and
sometimes it doesn't and I
I have the illusion that it damn much
better at recognizing who people are as
I grow older
but that could be just
cynicism no no it's not cynicism it's um
it's often more that I'm able to
recognize what somebody needs when we
interact and how we can meaningfully
interact it's not cynical at all you're
better at noticing yes I'm much better I
think in some stances and understanding
how to interact with other people then I
did when I was young so that takes us
doesn't mean that I'm always very good
at it so that takes us back to prompt
engineering of uh noticing how to be a
better prompt engineer of an llm a sense
I have is that there's a
bottomless well of skill to become a
great prompt engineer it feels like it
is all my fault whenever I fail to use
strategypt correctly that I didn't find
the right words
most of the stuff that I'm doing in my
life doesn't need to attribut there are
a few tasks that are where it helps but
the main stuff that I need to do like
I'm developing my own thoughts and
Aesthetics and relationship to people
and it's necessary for me to write for
myself because writing is is not so much
about producing an artifact that other
people can use but it's the way to
structure your own thoughts and develop
yourself and so I think this idea that
kids are writing their own essays with
chat GPT in the future is going to have
this drawback that they miss out on the
ability to structure their own minds via
writing and I hope that these schools
that our kids are in will retain the
wisdom of understanding what parts
should be automated and which ones
shouldn't but at the same time it feels
like there's power and disagreeing with
the
thing that your GPT produces so I use it
like that for programming I'll see the
thing it recommends and then I'll write
different code to disagree and in the
disagreement your mind grows stronger
um I'm recently wrote the tool that is
using the camera on my MacBook and Swift
to read pixels out of it and manipulate
them and so on and I don't know Swift
um so it was super helpful to have the
thing that is writing stuff for me and
also interesting that mostly it didn't
work at first I felt like I was talking
to a human being who's trying to hack
this on my computer without
understanding my configuration very much
and also make a lot of mistakes and
sometimes it's a little bit incoherent
so you have to I ultimately understand
what it's doing there's still no other
way around it but I do feel it's much
more powerful and faster than using
stack overflow